hi folks ron agronomist with pioneer in
central texas
you can see i'm in a field of corn
that's taking some pretty severe heat
skull due to drought conditions you can
look at these plants and see that the
top material is completely scalded very
little green left plants are starting to
shut down question i would have this
about this is what kind of yield can i
expect out of these particular plants
and will there even be any here's an air
on down the road let's go on down here
and see what it looks as we get across
here
notice as you go through here
a lot of these leaves are scorched very
little photosynthesis happening these
are still alive but severely rolled up
and of course the husks are starting to
turn turn by
so as we look right here
it starts to improve as we get on down
there so we've got an ear that i pulled
back there
let's investigate this a little bit and
see what it looks like
well number one you can tell right off
the bat
a little bit of incomplete pollination
probably due to drought and that piece
of soil is very very shallow back there
a lot of rock this is an air i pulled on
down the way
it's a little better shape but one of
the things you'll notice is some missing
kernels my expectation here is probably
that was a late roundup application we
had such severe dry weather early in the
season we didn't have weeds to spray at
the correct time you know v8 or 30
inches whichever comes first when you
have a drought a lot of times you
shorten the internodes you'll have
plants at a farther growth stage than
you ever imagined
so you could see looking here these uh
these ears are not going to yield that
well
but if you look down here at this board
where we've gathered two hybrids two
different ones new 1122 the new 095 at
differing populations they look pretty
decent well that's a different part of
the field
a little bit better soil and notice our
populations 25 22 18.
so 25 on this piece of land is probably
a little bit rich 22 is probably about
right and 18's on the low side
so
a question i would get is okay ron
what's gonna happen to these ears if
these plants die
well we're at the dent stage for the
most part or early dent you're not going
to abort kernels on the tip any longer
because you're at that advanced growth
stage what you will see though is you
will see these kernels shrivel they will
be very small like that
be very hard to get in the combine and
they will have very limited test weight
so can you still lose yield absolutely
kernel depth and test weight are going
to be the two culprits in this situation
again
little better soils
a lot better results
a lot of fields will be that way this
year i hope this helps you all have a
great harvest season
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights